what makes you female is having these um
large
sessile gametes and what makes you male
is having these small zippy gametes
but very often when humans especially
modern humans talk about it
they talk about being xx or xy right
they talk about the chromosomes and
in humans as
the vast majority of mammals there being
a few very weird exceptions at the base
of the mammal tree the monotremes the
echidnas and the duckbill platypus which
have like cot what is it like 10 or 12
pairs of sex chromosomes it's crazy i
thought it was five but anyways maybe
it's five and they got ten in pairs i
like i i don't actually remember um and
it's very it's variable between the
three or five species depending on how
many echidnas you think there are
anyway um the marsupials um and the
placental mammals the two other major
groups of mammals
which are basically every mammal that
you can think of that's not an echidna
or a duckbill platypus not basically
that is everything
have
uh what's called genetic sex
determination which means that we have
all of us
um a pair of chromosomes and if a pair
of sex chromosomes is opposed to all the
other autosomes that we have and it's
variable between species like um you
know humans have
23 pairs of chromosomes and that 23rd
one is the sex chromosomes
and i think bonobos um who are together
our closest living relatives have
is it 24 and their diploid number is 48
or is it 22 i think it's different than
ours
but i don't remember which way it is
yeah i think it's one more i i think so
too but i don't i don't totally remember
so you know and there's going to be i'm
sure there's other mammals out there
whose haploid number who's you know
how many how many pairs of chromosomes
do you have is 23 like ours um and um
they aren't going to be as closely
related to us as um as the chimps and
bonobos
and so in in us
in chimps in giraffes in kangaroos in
wombats in sperm whales even female
sperm whales um there is a pair of sex
chromosomes and if you have two x's
then you're female
and if you have an x and a y then you're
male but it's not that um
that is what underlyingly makes you
female it's that's what determines your
sex okay so in mammals we have xx
determines that you will become female
absent other weird developmental things
that might happen and if you're xy
that that the position at that last set
of chromosomes determines what sex you
are there are other species there are
other clades that have genetic sex
determination uh birds famously but in
birds it's the opposite and so we use we
use different letters to use w's and z's
but whereas in mammals females are the
homogeneic sex meaning we have two two
x's as opposed to the heterocommunic sex
for males and x and a y in birds uh
females are heterocommedic and they have
a y and a z and uh males are homocomedic
and they don't i don't never remember if
it's two w's or two z is whatever
um and that actually has
some interesting implications for how
their ecology plays out but they still
have genetic sex determination
whereas and we're just sticking to
vertebrates here there's lots of species
of vertebrates that don't have genetic
sex determination at all that don't
appear to have anything in their
chromosomes that says aha got it i'm
going to set you down the path to being
male or female they have some form of
environmental sex determination so um
in
many oviparous species for instance that
is egg-laying species as opposed to
viviporous species like us who give live
birth
you have the temperature of the egg at a
critical moment in development that
determines what sex you will be which
means at the point that that egg is laid
it is still open you still could become
male or female but any individual that
kind of doesn't become one or the other
isn't viable is an evolutionary dead end
and so just a few examples in tortoises
males develop
males develop from eggs that were in
that critical period at low temperatures
and females at higher temperatures
in many lizards and alligators it's the
opposite females develop at the lower
temperatures and males at the higher
temperatures and in crocodiles and
snapping turtles both cool and warm
temperatures during that critical period
during egg development um turn into
females whereas it's the intermediate
temperatures that produce males so
there's all sorts of ways to determine
whether or not you some developing
embryo are going to become male or
female and in species with environmental
sex determination uh there you know
things like if you live in a place that
is warming you might suddenly have a
population crash because now you've got
all females are all males this is going
to be a problem
whereas for organisms like mammals and
birds with genetic sex determination and
a few other and several other species as
well
the
the temperature at which we are
incubated doesn't seem to matter of
course with mammals we're endotherms and
we have viviparity um and so we've got
this constant internal
gestational environment but for for
birds who do lay eggs um yes mama and
depending on species papa birds sit on
the eggs and keep them warm but that
keeping them warm doesn't change what
sex they are because that's already on
board in their genetics so all of these
things are true
and none of it changes the underlying
thing which is that whether or not you
got there because you developed cool you
developed hot you had an xx you had a zw
if as an adult
you are capable of producing large
sessile gametes you are female
and if as an adult you are capable of
producing small zippy gametes you are
male and that cannot be changed
all right
now i want to add the thing that i think
is most surprising on top of all of that
really shocking stuff that you just laid
out okay
imagine that you walk into a forest
right imagine that you exist
five thousand years ago before we
understood any of this right
or imagine you landed on this planet
from somewhere else okay
it sounds like and you walk into a
forest and you find animals of some type
what we would call a species
and some of these animals are behaving
in a way
that is finicky about who to have sex
with
and some other animals are enthusiastic
to have sex with
whichever
ones will have them right
and you said okay i know nothing about
these creatures or how they work
but i'll bet you those ones that are
finicky
have big gametes and i bet you that the
ones that are
hot to trot
irrespective of the qualities of the
other
have
small motile gametes
you'll almost always be right
right and the reason for this is that
let's walk back a little bit so
presumably the initial condition is when
gametes so you have
uh asexual creatures that don't make
gametes at all there's an advantage to
uh fusing two half genomes together
right we can debate about what that is
and it's actually not entirely certain
it's a little harder to come up with a
robust argument for why the genetic
variation that comes from sex
reproduction is a good thing
we'll go into that some other day
but for the moment let's just say that
there's a reason that
natural selection invents sexual
reproduction repeatedly it's not for all
creatures but for many creatures it
appears to be essential
um
so selection invents this thing
presumably when it first does you get
two gametes that are the same size
right um we would call that isogamous
gametes
now isogamous gametes is a stable
equilibrium it's an unstable equilibrium
which means that you can't tell which
way it's going to go but it can't stay
where it is because as soon as one
type of creature
starts
creeping out on how much it invests in
these gametes the other one can't cheap
out in response it actually has to over
invest and so what you see
the additional problem well two
additional problems
are the reason for one of the sets of
gametes to be large is because you can't
make a baby just with uh dna right right
you need the cytoplasmic structure the
cellular machinery and someone's got to
bring that and if you both bring it if
both male and female bring it they're
going to argue
actually right they're going to argue
about who's cellular machinery to use
maybe and and in part because there is
mitochondrial dna right there's actual
genetic material in some of the
cytoplasm and then also if you're both
kind of move kind of middling size and
kind of both have some cytoplasm then
when you get together you might argue
about who's mitochondria to use
you're also both kind of slow and lumpy
and you're going to have a harder time
finding one another
so exactly as you say there's an
unstable um there's an unstable
equilibrium and so an unstable
equilibrium is kind of an uh hard
concept to grasp because
let's think about it this way if you did
a computer model of what happens if you
put a marble a perfect marble on
in exactly in the center balanced on the
head of a perfect pin
right
the computer will tell you that the
marble doesn't do anything it doesn't
fall off why because it doesn't know
which way to fall off it's equally
likely to fall off in all ways which
holds it right there now in our
experience this never happens because
there are no perfect marbles there are
no perfect pins and there is no
perfectly stable environment where you
won't have the tiniest bit of wind or
the tiniest shaking of the earth that
will cause it to be slightly more this
way than that way and once it's slightly
more this way than that way then it goes
that direction so
the point is the equilibrium is a
technical fact can i have zach show this
while you're talking so this is a figure
from
dalian wilson's
book from the 1980s
called the evolution of sex and behavior
i believe and this is
uh my computer is playing funny games um
and it's gonna be it's gonna be small
for you guys but um
it it describes the both the unstable
and the stable equilibrium the unstable
equilibrium of isogamy in which gametes
are the same size and both have
arguments about about mitochondrial dna
and have a hard time finding one another
and the anisogamy the unequal sized and
sort of structured gametes that results
that is a stable equilibrium all right
so
equal-sized gametes is the initial
starting condition it immediately breaks
apart in favor of a small motile and a
large sessile gamete
but the crazy part is once that happens
and it doesn't matter how many times
this process happens where selection
favors sexual reproduction produces
equal equal-sized gametes and then the
unstable equilibrium breaks apart and
creates one
uh
subtype that makes large gametes and one
subtype that makes small games every
time that happens
maleness and femaleness follow right
that is to say the characteristics that
cause the you know the behaviors of
these creatures follow because once
you're stuck with one of these kind of
gametes certain things make sense from
the point of view of selection and other
things don't make sense and so
well i guess i'd like for you to be
i
i think i want you to correct your
language there a little bit
the state of having a small zippy gamete
is the state of being male the state of
having a large sessile gamete is the
state of being female the
software that follows the behavior for
animals the behavioral manifestation the
choosiness the displayiness the you know
and all of these things that follow
are
for lack of better terms perhaps the
typically feminine the typically
masculine it's not the femaleness of the
maleness the females and the maleness
exist and they do not change based on
how it is that those organisms will
later behave let's put it this way i
agree with your correction but it's not
even software right because we see it in
plants where there is no software right
it's the behavior and now this is this
you're the one who wants to call it
software i'm always the one calling it
behavior and you say software is the
more inclusive term that includes plants
because i wouldn't say that plants have
a gender so that we're where we usually
get into this is what's the definition
of gender and i say it's the software of
sex right
in a plant and you know the point i love
to make is that even in a plant that is
a a hermaphrodite that has both
male and female right that produces both
actually i don't think there are
sequential hermaphrodites in plants are
there uh kind of
at least kind of because there are
plants that avoid self fertilization by
the gametes maturing so it's oh
different it's but yeah sort of short
time scale than the way animals do it
but it's a very short time scale yeah
like per flower yeah yeah um but
anyway the point is even in a flower
that has both male and female parts
right the female parts are reluctant
about sex and they put the male parts
through a test right a long corolla tube
that the pollen grains have to grow down
in order to reach the eggs whereas the
pollen grains are totally hot to trot
and they are not discriminating right so
in a plant that is wind dispersed it'll
produce lots of pond it lands anywhere
tries to fertilize whatever it lands on
the male uh
plant parts will
hire insects to carry their you know
to carry the the pollen grains out to
female plants it's always male insects
because they're also the ones who are
easily fooled because they're so eager
for sex well actually it's not because
it's bees yeah
and you're talking about uh the the
orchids
and such yeah yeah but anyway the point
is the
enthusiasm
for sex with strangers
tracks the gamete size even though
presumably this has nothing to do with
shared ancestry between animals and
plants because i don't even think the
common ancestor of these two things had
sexual reproduction
no no they they
they probably they did
um so sex evolves um boy i'm gonna have
to i'd have to go back and it's gonna be
some yeast like colonial
something or other right
um
well i mean it involves a few six of
those a few times yep but in the lineage
that you know when i say definitely back
500 million years we can track that and
maybe up to two billion years there's
you know there's a lot that happens in
that one to two billion years space and
i'm not sure how precise we can be about
exactly when that was and therefore when
uh in the branching between plants and
animals that was i i'm actually not sure
okay but the overarching point on which
i know we agree is that it is the
constraints of the mode of reproduction
that cause the behavior to become what
it is which then in creatures like us
becomes a software program that uh is
gender but but the point is the behavior
precedes there being any software
involved at all it's just a set of
strategies that make sense if you are
the small gaming producing type versus a
set of strategies that make sense if you
are the large gamete producing type
which means that male and female have a
meaning in the universe beyond something
beyond the gametes it's the strategy
that follows from the gametes right this
couldn't have less to do with people
right and people are in a sense
interesting because
in the sense the software
is partially sex role reversed in us
right a both males and females are
choosy right that exists in other
creatures but we are asymmetrically
choosy we choose for different things
which is pretty interesting
um and the ornaments both display yeah
yeah the ornamented sex is female right
typically if you find a displaying bird
or spider or something like this that's
the mail right and so
the it's not that these things don't get
changed around but the basic logic of
choosiness isn't uh
inverted
and even as the software changes and the
rules change and even if they didn't
we're just talking about averages and
there's plenty of masculine acting women
and feminine acting men it does not
change the underlying sex that they are
it does not it does not now the last
point i would make and then i want to
talk about oikos a little bit just a
little bit more on this topic all right
the the last point that i wanted to make
is
that the basic underlying logic of
basically males with their small gametes
are hot to trot because they're
investing
less in offspring gets changed
especially in something it gets changed
in any creature where there is teaming
up on raising offspring because
because the point is the logic is uh
unmade to the extent that males are
cheating on investment by producing
small gametes that contain very little
as soon as males are forced to invest
then they
view the world in a way that is more
symmetrical to the way females naturally
see it you would get more symmetry in
those species but you would also have
species with sexual reversal
where you have
something about the ecological
conditions has created a system in which
males are investing more than females so
something like polyandrous birds like
chicanas
or seaheas
seaheast which is our family term for
seahorses
where males are they do produce the
smaller gametes hence they're being
males but they engage in the pregnancy
they and they really i mean i actually
wrote a piece on my substance about this
um and i i had not i had not known
to what degree we understood the level
of
um
analogy
to uh to mammalian pregnancy that male
sea horses have i mean the the
cardiovascular and i believe
neurological but certainly
cardiovascular integration of the fetus
um with the father's body is
extraordinary in sea horses they really
yeah it's it's they are actually
pregnant and obviously you know the egg
didn't come from them so they brought
this in but then it embeds in a way that
is extraordinarily like pregnancy all
right so yeah the the way
you'll understand the point of this but
they're still males if this makes sense
to you there are things about the
interaction between the baby sea horses
and their father who is male because of
the gametes that he produces that are
beyond what you will understand that are
beyond what we understand that are
likely beyond what we will ever
scientifically understand about the
system
however
the um underlying logic of the system is
relatively easy to understand which is
if you're gonna invest you're going to
be choosing right yes that's the driving
force and the point is it takes no
complexity to see it right yeah and just
just think that through just think like
okay
if i'm going to invest
am i going to take everything that comes
at me
in any context at all like no if you're
going to invest you're going to be
choosy right there it is and so to the
extent that you have sophists arguing
that um you know it's the patriarchy
that uh caused
women to be
reluctant about casual sex just think it
through for yourself no freaking way
right the fact is if having sex is going
to stick you with a
an offspring that you're gonna carry
with you for nine months give birth to
and then have to take care of very
intensively for you know six seven eight
years and then you know to some extent
until it's 15 16 17
years of age right you don't want to
produce such a thing willy-nilly and you
don't want to produce it without an
agreement
to co-parent if such an agreement is a
possibility so hence females will be coy
about sex right that has nothing to do
with the patriarchy right in fact the
patriarchy protects women because
you know both men and women have an
interest in the women in their group
being protected from men who would
inseminate them and run off
there's plenty of places where the
patriarchy which is not a word i tend to
use
does not protect women at all or very
well and one of one of those places is
[Music]
another boy i heard from
uh is with what's happening now with
regard to our apparent inability to
understand what women are which is thus
allowing
men
to claim they're women and to beat women
in sports which is a much you know it's
it's it's both important and not nearly
as important as the fact that once you
have that then you start letting men
into women's prisons and
and you know and everywhere else like
all the dominoes fall
[Music]